how are you doing out there Aaron
Sampson here with Michael hyoma and
we're gonna talk about Ghost Recon break
points particularly what it is maybe not
quite what you expect now that we've
played a bunch of it we're going to talk
about some of the survival mechanics in
the game some of the investigations that
you do and all the game stacks up to
what it's been presented
let's talk about how this game is not
actually a survival game
moment-to-moment you know this is
something that the marketing materials
been hitting a bunch of I'm not saying
this is a good or bad thing basically
the way the game actually works itself
is it has these light survival elements
built into it but this game is very much
a Loutre shooter there's a social hub
you go out on daily faction missions and
it's just got that loot hook that all
these games have where you you shoot a
dude something drops on the ground with
a color you pick it up you figure out if
it's as good as the thing in your
inventory and you shred it or you sell
it and you kind of rinse and repeat that
a bunch of times in the environment it's
a compelling thing in a lot of games I'm
not sure people expected that from this
game which probably falls somewhere
exactly in between Ghost Recon wildlands
and the division I am surprised by how
much closer this is to the division
because you do have your score you are
going through that grind like oh is this
better than what I have now is is the
type of weapon that I want to use so
they're kind of blurring the lines
between those two games which I'm not
sure if you know I I really want that
because I've already played a ton of
division 2 this year and with Ghost
Recon kind of adapting a lot of those
elements a lot of those RPG elements I'm
afraid that this might be to say me and
I would want a little bit more variation
I mean that's not to say that break
point doesn't do those elements well
it's just it's encroaching on what
division 2 is trying to do it's really
interesting you bring up a good point
about the audience that this is going
for it feels like if you are somebody
who played the division and wanted
slightly better shooting mechanics and
slightly less RPG mechanics for example
and you know developers in this game
kept talking about how a head shot is a
head shot so no matter what level an
enemy is you can still like pop the
helmet and headshot them so if you
wanted that experience somewhere in
between those two games then actually
this is a this is a good choice but if
you were really into the hardcore RPG
elements of the division or just the
ability to screw around without any
consequences in wildlands you know you
have to think about where this game
lands as a sequel
Raye point has very light survival
elements so they are there there's this
thing like constant need to drink water
to replenish your stamina with cool
little small touches like you can't
replenish your canteen in salt water hmm
now in some ways you are being hunted
like the wolves who are the opposing
faction on the island they will pop up
every now and then and sort of put
pressure on you but it's not like it's a
constant threat it's there are ways to
get around at least in our time so it
didn't feel like it was overbearing but
also didn't feel as much of a factor as
maybe I had expected so that comes into
play there and like you said with
drinking water it'll take stamina way
from you if you're not hydrated so these
are these are kind of soft survival
elements that you at least have to think
about as you're going through the game
also on the survival side there the
bivouacs in this game which are camping
spots where you can rest save and
resupply items in terms of their
effectiveness this time around we did
not run out of ammo as much in this demo
as I did at e3 which is one of the big
reasons that they've whack our team was
fairly effective I didn't feel like we
needed to craft a lot of healing items
which again was a little bit different
from the way I played at e3 and there's
already checkpoints in the game so you
don't necessarily have to go to the
bivouacs to save so it seems like more
of an optional activity than we
originally saw yeah it does seem more
forgiving than again like I expected and
I'm fine with that I'm wondering if
there's gonna be I'm sure they'll be
more challenged to it but for at least
the early because we played about the
the Front's 5 or 6 hours of the game and
yeah maybe it opens up not sure quite
yet so the bivouac is more of a place
where if you have needs like you can
purchase helicopters back at the social
space and then spawn them at the at the
bivouac you cannot however bivouac
anywhere you want which I think was a
something that I thought when I first
saw this game there are very set
checkpoints around the map so if the big
blacks are jumping off points then we
can talk about the exploration of the
landscape and how things like
investigations are pretty different from
wild lands found a sketch of a map and a
picture of some kind of blueprints they
can't figure out what they're for now
let me take a look
my old brain might have the answer
somewhere in there I also found a key
card it's some kind of strange atomic
symbol on it so there are side missions
and breakpoint where you need to look at
the evidence in order to find out where
to go you have to pay attention to the
clues that they give you so for example
I'll go to an NPC and say al I'm taking
on this mission but you need to go to
this area the map we're not quite sure
where it is but this is what you need to
be looking for so I'm not gonna get a
waypoint or a Road marker to say this is
the most optimum route to get to your
objective instead you go into the menu
you look at your evidence and it'll tell
you you're looking for for example a
bunker in this area of the map maybe
it's in this location and you might be
looking for like dog tags or a
photograph or a map or something and
then you kind of have to pay more
attention to your environment you need
to pay attention to what things are
named in the map because with a lot of
these open-world games if you give me a
waypoint I'm just gonna go to it and do
what I need to do and I start to lose
familiarity or I don't get the
familiarity with what have the maps laid
out what these places look like and what
their names but now they're just giving
me evidence and now I'm looking at the
map very differently and considering
what I'm looking at in the environment
and that's really interesting to me
because yeah like I said you look at the
world differently and you're more in
tune with it at that point
yes yeah also the the HUD itself kind of
fed into that so you with the press of
one button who I believe was the d-pad
you could turn the HUD mostly off uh-huh
and just be in the world and I feel like
if there's one thing that kind of messed
up the experience of Ghost Recon
wildlands it was just this weird I know
where all the loot is and I'm just going
for the loot all the time and I don't
care about anything that's happening
around me you know in order to enjoy
wildlands I had to turn everything off
hardcore no HUD breakpoint taps into
that way better where it it can force
you to be in the environment so huh
that being said there is a guided mode
in which if you want to do that we
believe you can still get the markers
but it's off by default
yeah I'm not I'm not sure exactly what
guided mode gives or doesn't give you
but by default these missions are
kind of your left up to your own devices
an to looking at with evidence tells you
and where to go and yeah I think that's
my favorite part of break point so far
wait a minute you got a ring on his
finger it's the same one from Matt's
photograph just cow's body I think the
next thing we want to talk about is just
sort of the some of the because I want
to get this game credit some of the
really good things and some of the
things that feel a little bit off to me
the lute felt pretty good to me like I
actually genuinely enjoyed firing most
of the weapons I enjoyed new things
dropping on the ground all the time it's
got that good lute thing that and I
think it's something you talked about a
lot of the movie games are starting to
head towards like there's a Assassin's
Creed and a bunch of games is sort of
headed in this direction yep
the weapons still do that genius thing
from wildlands each weapon remembers if
you were first person or over the
shoulder which is such a good little
touch yeah and the the weapon control
menu is very very granular so if you're
a shooter fan there's just a lot for you
to play with here stuff that I wasn't
quite sure about was and they talked
about this doing this on purpose but the
movement was a little floaty can be
sometimes hard to get to the piece of
cover you wanted because your character
takes another couple steps if there's
momentum and yeah there's a lot of wind
up again if you're trying to change
direction or if you're trying to move in
like miniscule ways and that's less of
an issue in PvE but once you get into
PvP where you're playing against other
people precision matters and also the
characters are very the cameras are
zoomed in on the character I think some
of that is for immersion to give you
that feeling like you don't know what's
around you
but the character can't block your view
sometimes particularly in PvP but you
also have a character that carries with
you across all of the modes so if we
want to talk about PvP this is starting
to turn into a little bit more of maybe
a destiny scenario where a weapon that
is no longer good in the environment is
a gun that you may want to hold on to in
PvP because it's like a sniper rifle
still sniper rifle right let me tell you
snap a rifles were king in the PvP that
we play yeah yeah at least for the early
matches that we were playing I like that
they're unifying progression you know
Mike McCarty was talking a lot about
this with his time in break point I
think that's probably one of the things
that stood out to him
is that the game is respecting your time
because if you want to spend a bunch of
time in PvP and you'll get upgrades and
all that stuff for the same character
that you'll take into the single-player
stuff it makes sense at this point
because you know time is a limit these
are big games and I don't want to you
know divvy up all of my progression so
that that's sensible and yeah I'm I'm a
big fan of that and we kind of dominated
the other team and a little bit I know
maybe maybe the i/o they might be we saw
plans trying to make us feel good but
you know we had we had a good time there
all right breakpoint is out on October
4th uh-huh we'll be playing in a bunch
when it comes out so for more info on
Ghost Recon breakpoint at uni GameSpot
thank you your masters they just they
don't believe in anything we'll make you
an offer no mad
[Music]
you